i'm not trying to come across like all
this situation like i'm not trying to
victimize myself i don't want pity i
don't deserve pity
we messed up i just want a second chance
to be like i recognize i messed up
olivia jade appeared on red table talk
tuesday and
opened up for the first time about the
college admissions scandal that landed
both of her parents in prison
and now a source is opening up to e.t
about how the 21 year old youtube star
and her family are ready to move forward
and reclaim their careers
and i think every single person in my
family can be like that was messed up
that was a big mistake but i think
what's so important to me is like
to learn from the mistake not to now be
shamed and punished and never given a
second chance because i'm
21 i feel like i deserve a second chance
to redeem myself to show i've grown
the source tells e.t quote olivia is
looking forward to modeling again
and getting social media deals she knows
she can capitalize on those facets of
the industry right now but
also knows she needs to re-prove herself
in a huge way
when i was on youtube it was so well
just come along with my world like see
where i'm at let's just go for
my journey right and i now when i go
back i just want to make it very clear
and very aware like
there are big problems going on in the
world but how much better of a person
would you be if you
used your blessings to help somebody
else as for olivia's mom
lori laughlin who is currently serving
her two-month prison sentence after
pleading guilty in may
to one count of conspiracy to commit
wire and mail fraud
and on a services wire and mail fraud
our source says
she feels hopeful about her career
especially since felicity huffman who
was also involved in the scandal
just landed an acting role in an
upcoming abc
comedy after serving 11 days behind bars
she is supportive of felicity lori feels
as though they experience this together
in a way
and she has felicities back by extension
and the source says the whole family
wants to put this behind them
and do their best to move on and grow
and succeed together and
individually i want them to be happy so
i want to be supportive of everything
they want to do
they are hopeful that people brands
companies friends and family don't judge
them
or their children as a result of their
mistakes and according to our source
they know that they were absolutely in
the wrong i'm really sorry that this
happened or
i really own that this was a big mess up
on everybody's part
but i think everybody feels that way in
my family right now
the whole situation ended up being more
horrifying than they could have
ever anticipated they are so remorseful
and are determined to make things right
you